[Music]
[Applause]
i mentioned this earlier in the week the
time frame of charles barkley meeting
with the live tour also his thoughts
also the possibility that gary mccord
would be joining the live tour and uh
mccord's good buddy david faraday has
also already announced that he is
joining the uh live tour andrew marchand
has been uh at the head of this story
more than anybody else new york post
sports media columnist co-host of
marshawn and iran the sports media
podcast you spoke with charles what was
your uh feeling that uh what he was
going to do with the live tour
he said he'd love to do both turner and
live that was kind of ideal for him
obviously it depends on how much money
they're going to offer him um i reported
and charles confirmed that he makes 10
million a year from turner then you had
his endorsements which i don't know that
number but
you got to think three to five maybe um
so liv's going to have to come with a
big number uh that said i think turner
knew that the market has changed with
the tom brady 375 million dollar deals
uh
troy aikman tony romo making 18. he got
the greatest studio
uh analyst of all time iconic show
inside the nba at 10 million again it's
a lot of money but they kind of knew
that i think a new deal was coming
anyway
i got a figure
to get charles attention maybe 25
million dollars and if you look at what
he means i mean look at the publicity
he's generated far more than dustin
johnson or bryson deschambeau i mean
charles could renegotiate right now in
the past couple of days to say look at
all the attention that i'm bringing you
i guess the curiosity of this is will
tnt allow him to do this
so he's charles barkley right this is
different than if it's me right uh he's
so important to inside the nba
they do have a good relationship
and um i think ultimately if he says
look i want to do live uh i don't think
they're gonna say uh they're not just
gonna let them go right they're gonna
either offer more money and give them a
huge say hey look we'll match the money
or come close to it you just have to do
your regular job you get a huge raise
and it works out for you or they say you
know what we'll let you do these events
but we want you on inside the nba maybe
you change the schedule a little bit but
not that much uh i don't really i think
it's it's possible i don't really see a
scenario where barkley's not on turn i'd
be really surprised if that's the final
where we end up here
i wondered
that he did the interview with you he
did an interview with the pga tour
podcast
almost kind of sending up that trial
balloon to say let me kind of
kind of guess which way the winds are
blowing here
did you get any sense of that that he
sort of wanted to
get feedback before he makes the
decision
yeah he's very smart and he's his own
man so i don't know like
there could be a method to you know the
whole thing of what he's doing um
if you were trying to kind of get some
more leverage with turner this would be
a good way to approach it uh but i do
think he's interested in it i mean he's
going to play in the pro am next week at
trump's bedminster
golf club in new jersey uh before their
next event which is going to be a scene
for sure um and that kind of made sense
to me again i i don't know if he thought
it this out but you know that's going to
be because of trump uh because it's near
new york and 9 11. there's gonna be a
lot of attention on that and i don't
think the attention really is gonna be
on barkley that much you know a little
bit but it'll be more on the golfers
more on trump more on the event and kind
of he's already kind of then he'll put
his uh foot you know that you know okay
i've played it with their um with this
group uh and then if you were to go i
think it kind of lessens it and i will
say this is the other thing that i
think's very
like everyone in media should follow
charles because like i asked him every
question i don't think you know you know
i think i asked him every question and
he just answered them all right he
didn't he even brought up you know
because his big thing that everyone
takes blood money uh and he even brought
up he nike which endorses him like no
one else would do that right only
charles barkley but it i do think it
helps him just to answer the questions
because he's already answered his
questions and what he thinks um and you
can disagree with him you can agree with
him whichever but he's explained himself
and i feel like the golfers especially
just have done you know they're not
charles barkley but they just had no
answers and they knew the questions were
coming you think you'd have a little bit
more of some answers
how do you get your money out of barkley
if you're the live tour
i think they already have like i think
okay i quite honestly you know part of
it like you know when you read the
article i wrote
and you hear his reasoning like you
again might not like it but at least
it's coherent and makes sense of what
he's saying he's pointing that other
people are in uh business with the
saudi-backed um
you know the same the same group that's
uh backing greg norman and liv um and so
that's one way i also think he adds
credibility and in his dinner with greg
norman norman
told berkeley because according to
barkley that he thinks they're going to
get a tv deal uh you bring in charles
barkley it helps you get a tv deal again
best studio analyst sports analyst of
all time uh that helps you with
credibility you have ferrari already in
you already brought in arlo white uh you
have a credible broadcast it doesn't
it's not a bunch of like no names doing
this this is a this is a good broadcast
that they could potentially have now you
know uh if you're a huge golf guy do you
wanna hear from charles barkley maybe
maybe not but but he is fun and he's
just he's a very entertaining guy yeah i
like him when it's gimmicky golf when
it's the match and it's rogers and and
brady and he can lighten them up a
little bit
um some comic relief
the live tour
okay
i mean i would have him play in every
event you know that like if if you're
gonna have fun with him and have him
miked up on the course
and and have him interact with players
something like that
as far as the tv partner or media
partner who you're hearing might uh
carry the live tour and dan let me just
want to piggyback on what you just said
uh he did say that with his talks with
norman it was more of a smorgasbord of
things it doesn't seem like he's going
to do straight analysis so it does sound
as if like what you're the kind of how
you said to use them that's might be
where they're thinking uh in terms of a
tv deal now i think they've met with
everybody you know just to sort of you
know kind of have an initial meeting you
know people take meetings uh but i don't
think anything's there yet um you know a
lot of people have pointed to people who
have relationships uh with the pga maybe
they wouldn't be interested uh so you
look you know turner internationally
with the merger they do have a
relationship with the pga but you know
turner um that makes some sense maybe
fox and you know i don't think greg
norman and fox really ended on great
terms but when you think about um
distribution right this is going to be a
big money deal right we're not talking
you know the nfl type billion dollar
deals this is gonna be you're not gonna
have to pay that much and the more top
golfers that go
um this is becoming a legitimate
business
and
it's not i don't the focus that we're on
now
is probably going to fade because just
the questions will stop being because
there's not going to be more answers
there's not and the questions will kind
of stop eventually at least to a degree
and so and i think getting barkley let's
say they bring in barkley and his
sponsors don't drop him i do think that
kind of changes the game a little bit
well i think subway is trying to branch
out into saudi arabia so i don't think
that they're going to be dropping him
and i i mean he could do commercials
there capital one i i i don't know if
they're going to kick him to the curb
we're talking to andrew marsha on the
new york post sports media columnist
david ferrity
felt like he had been marginalized a
little bit by nbc and golf channel used
to be very very popular there at age
what 62-63 probably thought you know
what grab a paycheck have some fun right
off into the sunset uh uh what what was
the reaction from nbc when faraday
decided that he wanted to leave yeah
they let him out um pretty
seems easily like you said they
cancelled his golf channel show
he wasn't as
vital on their broadcast i come he came
over from cbs what maybe seven eight
years ago uh where you know he kind of
was at his peak uh and so yeah i don't
think he was really happy with them and
then like you said i don't know the
exact numbers for what faraday got but
it definitely was a substantial raise
the amount and and less work you know so
it's uh you know when you again getting
there's a political aspect to this and
the civil rights civil liberty and you
know the killing of a journalist there's
a lot of really serious things um and so
i don't want to
make those make any light of those but
when you just look at it in terms of
what his day-to-day life is uh it's more
money and less work um and probably
will be more of a focus in terms of you
know how the broadcasts are presented
it's a great concept uh uh more money
less work
you know a lot of people i think
everybody is looking at that i'd sign up
for that no i wouldn't i wouldn't go to
the uh live tour um
the nfl broadcasting look how will it
look differently this season
it's going to be massively different i
mean let's start with monday night
football you'll see joe buck and troy
aikman there
that was a huge move and another big
money move
aikman signed a five-year 90 million
dollar contract buck signed a five-year
75 million dollar deal so they leave fox
they go to espn for monday night
football monday night finally kind of
stabilizes that booth after a long time
we're kind of going with different folks
uh at fox he's they're replaced by kevin
burkhart uh who's one of the more
likable guys in the business uh who
moves up from the two slot to one and
then greg olsen uh will be
his partner uh and then tom brady's in
the on deck circle uh waiting to to be
the number one when he finally stops
playing uh um you go to nbc
they
let al michaels go they want to go with
mike tarico so mike tarico is now your
play by player on sunday night football
with chris collinsworth they also have a
new sideline reporter and melissa stark
and for michelle tafoya uh and then al
went to amazon which is gonna be the big
probably the biggest story you talk
about all these things i think amazon
this is an historic thing for sports
media and how you watch games amazon's
going to have exclusive rights to
thursdays and it's going to be al
michaels and kirk kirk street in that
main booth
this is a serious question
okay
who has more money
amazon
or the live tour and their backers
that that's a good question i would say
the live tour teams have more money to
spend like amazon still they kind of
have a business going and so you know
they've been on some deals like
champions league is coming up and i
think they're gonna go heavy for it um
but like and you know like amazon apple
can just spend whatever they want it's
not really gonna impact them but they
they treat i mean as they should and why
they're so successful i mean they treat
it as businesses the live tour at this
point
um i've had people you know in the golf
tv world not really feel like this they
really have a business
plan here uh so i would say they have
more money to quote burn
did chris collinsworth get a bump in his
pay that's up there with uh tony romo
and uh troy chris collinsworth yeah i
reported that before so the nbc did a
good job kind of locking him up so chris
collinsworth's gonna have to make do at
a mere 12 and a half million dollars a
year uh working you know five six months
on that
so he's not getting the 18 million
dollars but he uh
boxed out drew brees and i got a new
deal for 12. he's also i think doing
very well with that pff i think that's
doing well i think that's uh going to be
it is or is going to be a money maker
for him how did nbc miss on drew brees
that he was
like was he brought in to be the heir
apparent for chris collinsworth on
sunday night football i mean they'll
claim no but obviously yes right like if
he nailed it he was great in studio and
then was awesome on notre dame games now
i would say this i don't think drew
brees is as bad as everyone made him out
to be right like i don't think he had a
bad playoff game um it was a tough spot
he hadn't done nfl games it did move a
little quick and he sort of it was very
strange down the end it was just tarico
talking it was just an odd bad broadcast
that said
plenty of people have had bad broadcasts
and have to be curious i don't look so i
so i'm not as low on drew brees i also
wasn't as high on him coming out this
doesn't seem to have that personality
that you want um
you know i think he could be like an
aikman type
who has a little more personality but
kind of gives you that you know real
quarterback x and o's kind of thing uh
but uh so i don't know i think brees
he's not going to end up at fox i think
if you want to stay in this the move was
to go to fox and be the number two and
re-establish yourself maybe he does a
little you know a game or three with uh
amazon some kind of you know quarterback
thing but uh uh
yeah i don't know the the ship i might
it might have sailed a little bit
because if there's a number one job drew
brees is not getting that so unless he's
willing to take a two uh i don't think
we're gonna see him in the booth
good to talk to you again andrew thank
you have a good weekend thanks dad
that's andrew marchand new york post
sports media columnist